[Música]
con limón y agua en contra de este
fiasco
[Música]
interiores
hola árabe gracias por compartir este
momento con nosotros centrados 24
gracias a ustedes estás en columbia para
dos conciertos y el primero está acá en
bogotá
para un festival solamente con mujeres
artistas como ves este festival y cómo
te sientes de tocar al lado de estas
artistas colombianas
emocionada y un honor y
esto es como una conmoción venir en este
momento histórico
en donde hay un
un proceso histórico
de de paz y un proceso
de las mujeres por el aborto legal que
acaba de ser ley y que
intentamos con estos con estos eventos
que son más que eventos no son son
cuestiones importantes es más que un
concierto es
es una acción directa y política para
sostener estos logros como son el aborto
legal y si es un concierto donde voy a
compartir con un montón de artistas
mujeres y que me encantan que quiero
conocer y bueno estoy súper contenta
agradecida de que me hayan invitado y
claro como he escrito letras que tienen
que ver con
con movimientos y causas sociales
letras que
que narran
situaciones de abuso de poder
entonces por eso estoy acá
en esta vereda y de este lado
y es un orgullo y me parece muy
importante acompañar este momento y este
movimiento
social ahora histórico en colombia
tienes letras que salieron de las salas
de concierto de los hogares
y de las fiestas para llegar a las
calles y sobre todo las prostestas a las
marchas
feministas cuando es esto en foto en
vídeo cuando tú te vas a marchar también
que sientes y era uno de tus objetivos
es que no lo tenía común no lo hice
pensando en eso como objetivo yo lo hice
y después
apareció
encantado gritado
en la calle en las movilizaciones hay un
ida y vuelta creo que mis canciones ya
están escritas en la calle y están
dichas en las movilizaciones y por la
gente creo que
una narradora un narrador un escritor
una escritora
somos ladronas y siempre estamos
escuchando para después armar en
nuestras en lo que escribimos
poner estas frases que están dichas por
otras por o tres por otras personas no y
bueno es un buen robo
entonces muchas de mis frases están
escritas en la calle pero las
artículo con con mi poética y ahí
resurge una especie de
de canción social
un poco himno y para mí es una emoción y
me emociona mucho cuando veo a las
chicas cantando mis canciones de las
movilizaciones y ahí digo si bien jara
[Música]
un movimiento social de trabajo
con ella
[Música]
vienes de la capital argentina de buenos
aires que vive al ritmo literal de las
marchas que si a veces casi todos los
días parece que es una ciudad que tiene
en su adn
las protestas pienso bueno en la marea
verde que hemos visto esos últimos años
todo el movimiento feminista pero
también pienso en las abuelas de la
plaza de mayo cuál fue la influencia de
esta ciudad sobre tu trabajo de buenos
aires-
bastante pero mira yo nací en chubut
patagonia argentina y tiene una historia
de lucha también muy muy fuerte un
territorio
saqueado
históricamente y actualmente con una
lucha muy viva y muy importante de toda
la población de chubut
y alrededores de la patagonia argentina
en contra de la megaminería en contra de
los ecocidios y del saqueo que están
haciendo bueno las grandes corporaciones
y empresas
en el norte de argentina también
entonces sí buenos aires- es grandísima
yo fui cuando termine la escuela a los
18 años a estudiar una cosa y terminé
haciendo esto pero si me sirvió mucho
para acercarme a otras y otros y otros
artistas para acercarme al teatro que
también fue una escuela en un momento
estudie de actuación me gusta mucho la
actuación en el mundo de del teatro
popular del cine también de la danza y
me sirvió mucho y me dio letras y buenos
aires- me dio mucha letra porque hay más
gente entonces tengo más para escuchar
pero siento mi identidad de la patagonia
del sur que tiene una gran historia del
saqueo y de lucha hasta el día de hoy y
quiero destacar
el momento actual que se vive de lucha
de gente que está ahí en la calle este
contra contra la megaminería y el saqueo
y bueno
creo que ambientalmente está crítica a
la situación en el mundo y en toda
latinoamérica y hay mucha gente luchando
y poniendo el cuerpo y esto es está
[__] y encontrarse como inspiración en
estos lugares en esta gente de nuestras
energías eso es como las fuentes de tu
inspiración siempre fue todo es fuente
de inspiración para mí todo cada cosa
todo todo todo todo pero sí
estas cuestiones que tienen que ver con
la ecología al principio siempre
escribía mucho sobre eso cuestiones
ecológicas
porque me parece si tan importante tener
un mundo donde siga habiendo agua
y vida
está todo se escuchan discursos tan
delirantes
d
de los gobernantes y de la gente que
está en el poder y que son tan
conservadores y conservadoras discursos
delirantes de saqueo discursos que
tienen que ver con con regar todo con
glifosato
y con las extracciones
y a la vez nosotros somos parte de esto
también no con la tecnología
utilizando el litio vivo una
contradicción y a partir de ahí escribo
así que si siempre fue su inspiración
las luchas si las luchas de
de las mujeres de las travestis de la
gente tan hostigada día a día de esa
gran pena
y de hoy
estoy haciendo canciones nuevas en donde
hablo más de cuestiones íntimas
muy íntimas pero sigue estando la
esencia de estas cosas que me conmueven
y que me preocupan nos entonces un poco
de la esencia está pero no quiero
repetirme
total lo que escribí sigue vivo en cada
concierto cada vez que lo canto o cada
vez que se escucha esto lo sigo pensando
lo que dije lo sigo sintiendo entonces
es también quiero permitirme escribir
sobre otras cosas porque si no sería
como una
alienación también no de muy panfletaria
muy como de repetir una queja no sacamos
una foto no ponemos
[Música]
reggaeton antifa para que la gente lo
baile como quiere rompiendo las redes a
lo guapo pélata tan con la cola peleando
como quiere cuando los periodistas le
preguntan sobre el hecho de crecer y
entrar en géneros musicales entre
comillas de hombres contestas de lo que
leí que al final no fue tan difícil para
ti pero que tú hablas mucho de la
presión
sobre las artistas a ser más
perfeccionistas y sobre la necesidad
también de desarrollarse en lugares en
ámbitos más alternativos como solución
frente a este problema es una
perspectiva que ya tenías cuando
empezaste y son consejos que te gustaría
dar por ejemplo las nuevas generaciones
de artistas miriam o no yo creo que a
las nuevas generaciones de artistas no
les tengo que dar ningún consejo porque
son excelentes soy admiradora de todas
las jóvenes me parece que como decía
recién
las lees y los jóvenes son una versión
mejorada mejor andy sima de la humanidad
tengo un sobrino de tres años y medio
que filósofo ya un genio total y bueno y
las chicas de 1820 y los chicos también
me encantan la música que hacen en
argentina y grandes haciendo
producciones perfectas no así que más
que decir algo decir que sigan y que no
necesitan que yo les diga nada
pero si estaría bueno esto de tratar de
buscar eso singular que tenemos cada uno
y de tener un poquito en no permitir que
este monstruo
estético haga qué
que todo se vea igual y suene todo igual
para poder ser vendido pero creo que ya
lo saben igual
hay artistas que me encantan y hacen
cosas singulares y sobre estas nuevas
generaciones de artistas y que tienes
como costumbre de invitar a artistas
emergentes a abrir tus fechas si me
gusta y también en el disco nuevo hay
hits con artistas emergentes de argel de
argentina y también hay una canción con
amateurs que la amo una gran amiga y una
gran referente a nati chups de chile
y de francia también y con otras chicas
nuevas y argentinas que son geniales y
me gusta así me gusta me encanta soy fan
de la juventud y también de las grandes
que me enseñaron y que me mostraron este
camino
a la mitad
donde no hay poder hay vida